Is there anything you can do about the numbness around my axillary area from my mastectomy surgery last September or is it too late?
But doing some dry brushing is there a rife program?
I also touch one area I feel weird, zingy, and feeling than another.
I figure it's just nerves.
I would say most likely, yes, it's just nerves.
And when they do surgery, it's going to kill off nerve endings.
You know, you have nerves that go to every cell of your body.
And of course, they're going to do surgery.
They're going to re you're severing those nerves.
So there's some things that even if you jumped on it right away, trying to do dry brushing the nerve stimulation,
I think you still have the numbness. It doesn't make any difference.
So that can go away over time because nerves do grow back and about,
I think it's like a millimeter a month.
So those can grow back and infiltrate that tissue.
But there's not a lot more that you could do for it.
I know vitamin B6 can help with nerve pain if it's a neuropathy type thing.
You might want to consider taking some vitamin B6.
But I don't know there's a whole lot you could do about that.
But I don't know there's a whole lot you could do.